it's just robin hooded an arrow which is
where you shoot an arrow down the back
of another arrow it's actually really
hard to do with wooden arrows
it's a lot easier to do with with sort
of monaro's because they're a tube of
carbon my name is jim ken i'm also known
as grizzly jim and i'm a traditional
archer i've been shooting bow and arrow
for 35 years today we're going to be
looking at some archery scenes from tv
and film and seeing how kind of
realistic they are
[Music]
he's got what we call a cant on the bow
there i tend to shoot with a with a
little bit of a cant it opens up the
sight windows if your bows up straight
like that generally the thing you're
trying to shoot is going to be hidden by
the bow so i tend to drop the the bow
out the way a little bit which is what
he's doing he's clearly pointing one way
but you can see the arrow on his hand
pointing the other way and a lot of
people call that the archer's paradox
the arch's paradox is the fact that the
arrow's pointing off to the to the left
when you're actually pointing at the the
target at the right that's the paradox
and it's the flexing of the arrow that
makes it uh travel downrange
could i kill this dude running away
depends on the distance i'm only really
accurate up to
uh
probably about 30 meters i'd get him
eventually see i'd be zigging and
zagging i'd be i'd be serpentine
there is a type of archery called the
clout
typically done by
english longbow archers which is long
distance
um
where you shoot at a flag in the ground
sort of you know 180 200 yards away
shooting up shooting down closest to the
flag so there are people that can shoot
very very well at long long range
medieval longbow archers would you know
could be pretty accurate the bow looked
like it had
what they called pony limbs where
you've got the basic bow and then you'd
have another set of limbs that come off
the front so that limb is attached to
that limb and that limb is attached to
that limb and that gives you
way more power so it would be perfect
for that kind of you know
killing dudes running away kind of
archery i'm going to give him a nine for
game of thrones i think
[Music]
compound bow
is typically uh sort of either a target
style or a hunting bow you can you
basically you can adjust the angle that
the limbs are at
and if you wind them in it gives you a
little bit more power and i think what
he's doing there he's maximizing his
power on his compound bow
now you can buy arrows that come in
parts that's not how arrows work that's
that's just asking for trouble there are
points in an arrow that that flex and if
you are cutting an arrow into three and
assembling it it's not going to behave
like it should
[Music]
now
that there that's that's john rambo's
grenade tipped arrow there was a type of
broadhead you could buy
and it came in a case like that i think
that's just the case of a broadhead
sprayed bronze
[Music]
shooting left-handed so that's okay
but i know
later on he shoots he shoots it
right-handed the arrow flight on that is
is
utter garbage i mean he's shooting okay
shoot the compound off his fingers which
is which is fine compounds tend to use a
release aid which gives you a much
straighter release well i mean this type
of bow the further you pull it back the
higher the poundage gets a compound bow
starts high
and gets lighter so you can hold it at
full draw for long periods of time a
little bit more sort of fast a bit more
powerful
grenade tipped arrow yeah they do exist
whether or not they're commercially
available i i don't know everything else
look really good the way he was setting
up the bow the way he was changing his
poundage and everything i like that and
the fact that he shot the arrow it flew
like garbage but if you you know got a
grenade sitting on the end of the arrow
it probably would fly like that so
weirdly i think he's probably quite
realistic i'm going to give rambo an 8.
[Music]
there's a huge tennis ball on the end of
her arrow the more weight you put on the
front of an arrow the the less efficient
it's going to be it's just not going to
go very far let me just fix this give me
a second
there's a little grabber or something on
the end of that arrow again that's going
to add even more weight it's not a case
of one arrow
fits all
arrows come in spine weights and that
refers to the stiffness of the arrow and
obviously certain bows need a certain
spine weight so the higher the poundage
the bow the stiffer the arrow needs to
be and vice versa so by adding a lot of
weight to the front of the arrow you
dynamically weaken the spine of the
arrow so therefore the arrow would be
out of spine and it would probably just
veer off to the to the right and not hit
the bell at all you can shoot something
called a blunt which is a flat arrowhead
which would be for
either stomp shooting shooting tin cans
you know that kind of thing or small
game hunting
she's moving her arm up
and when you're shooting at distance
whether it's it's low down or high up
you don't really move your arm you you
move from the waist so you kind of pivot
your whole body uh not just your arm up
and down that's something i just spotted
the shot itself
not very realistic at all
uh but her shooting is is pretty good
we'll go five five out of ten
in the middle
[Music]
you've got
really long arrows there it looks like
she's only using two fingers on the
string one above one below i've seen
people do that
so she and she's got quite a quite an
overdraw there
she's got this explosive release
which
again
in order to make a good archery shot you
need to keep it concise and simple
because something like that you're not
going to be able to repeat it time and
time again if you've got a simple
release that comes back
you can repeat that
you've got to be
safe with everything you film and i
imagine
that bow was probably a very real bow
but it was probably such low poundage
and had such a stretchy string
that it goes straight back to being
a straight piece of wood the distance
between
the the lowest point of the bow and the
string that's called the brace height
if your bracelet is too low your bow
becomes very noisy it becomes quite
quick but it becomes very noisy and
you're really really in danger of
getting some real nasty string burn on
you on your arm
shooting multiple arrows
off a bow at the same time what happens
is because you've got all the energy
comes from from from the limbs and
pulling the string back and and what
that does it pushes the arrow forward
and the heavier the arrow that it needs
to push the more energy it needs to to
sort of get that arrow to where it needs
to go but if you're shooting multiple
arrows essentially the bow doesn't have
those multiple arrows on there it just
thinks there's a really heavy arrow two
arrows is double the weight you know and
the more arrows you put on the heavier
weight that bow is going to need to push
push the arrows through the air and it
basically just takes all the guts out of
the boat we'll give one a woman a five
they did they did all right
in order to shoot well you need to be
able to move so i think the fact that
they've got her in a tight thing and she
can't shoot properly i think it's
brilliant
archery is all about keeping everything
straight the less influence you can have
over the bow the better the arrow is
going to fly so if you're influencing
the shot
the shot's not going to go right so if
you can keep everything nice and simple
which she's doing she's coming back on
the same plane as the arrows going
forward
archery is all about being able to
repeat the shot time and time again
there's a famous book called the art of
repetition which is all about archery
and if you can replicate your shot time
and time again you will be a fantastic
archer she seems to have a nice
repeatable kind of form there
now look at look at this loose the trick
is with archery is you don't let go of
the string the trick is to try and no
longer be holding the string so you've
got to relax your hand let the hand flow
back if you're kind of trying to open
your hand as hard as you can you'll
never beat the string the string is
going to be quicker than your reactions
across the board so if you can just just
get your anchor point and then relax
your hand and let it come back you're
going to get a much smoother release and
you can see your hand just just relaxes
a lot of people think arrows fly
straight they don't if you watch an
arrow in slow motion it's like a wet
noodle uh going down range
just robin hooded an arrow which is
where you shoot an arrow down the back
of another arrow and the grain tends to
split but the grain never runs perfectly
parallel down the back of an arrow it
will always kind of peel off it's
actually really hard to do with wooden
arrows
it's a lot easier to do with with sort
of modern one arrows because they're a
tube of carbon and and it's easier to
kind of put an arrow down the back of
another one that's ten
one of the best representations
of the way uh an arrow and a bow work
together
get a lot of straight stuff in your tail
try to work out what bow that is
obviously it's got some gadgets on it it
could be a modified hoyt buffalo
spray black
he's using a finger and thumb draw which
which isn't really necessarily going to
going to work for that kind of thing
hawker that's a bit of a mess dude he's
got a shooting glove which is good to
see he's got a couple of arm guards on
there as well that's what's called a
biter arm guard that's just a make of of
arm guard thin strip of plastic and it
just protects you from the from the the
sort of the string as as it sort of
vibrates back to to where it's supposed
to go sometimes it can just catch your
arm
um let me just give you a little sting
so you tend to have a little bit of an
arm guard who just protects you
traditional archers tend to wear like a
bit more of a leather kind of bracer you
wouldn't wear two unless you're doing
something really wrong but they can't
bank with a dam
if you can't look at it how are you
going to shoot it the trend with these
kind of dynamic things is is that
there's never any kind of anchor point
it's always just
pull it back and let it go from whatever
position you're in which which is fine
but you're not gonna get that kind of
level of accuracy that he gets like he's
shooting moving targets now there is a
famous trick shot but
you're looking in a mirror and i've
tried it and i'm
almost succeeded
[Music]
he's got what maybe
36 arrows maximum when he first starts
it's like filmed with guns you get
people shooting
they never seem to have to reload but it
looks like it's fun so i'm gonna have to
give it four
too slow
fast as you can
again come on people can um
knock arrows out of the air it's not
something i would recommend trying
because if you get it wrong you only get
one chance i want people to enjoy
archery but i also want people to be
really safe when it comes to archery
there's a huge safety element to it
although a bow isn't classed as a weapon
it's classed as sporting goods um
it can be used as a weapon the shooting
arrows are the guy and he's
knocking him out the air i'd hate for
some kids to think hey let's try that
and and do it and get hurt it would
break my heart
try the other side it will save you a
second on the reload
he gets to uh show him a different way
of shooting now this this all came from
lars anderson video that came out a few
years back and it kind of turned the
archery world on his head and he
suggested that you took the arrow from
the left side of the bow to the right
side of the bow
which which goes from essentially a
western style of archery to an eastern
style of archery changing anything in
archery is a slow process takes time for
your body to get used to such a change
and going from from one side of the
bow to the other it would take time
come on
okay
if you shoot the arrow on the right side
of the bow with a mediterranean release
one finger above the arrow
two fingers below what happens is the
arrow v is wildly off uh to the right
which isn't ideal and there are people
that can shoot a mediterranean style
release like like the way they get robin
hood to do in this film you've got to
pull pull the bow out this way if you're
doing big dynamic movements to try and
get the arrow to go straight they're
very difficult to repeat so you're not
going to be fantastically accurate with
them is this something that i personally
i'm not a huge fan of there are people
that shoot hybrid style sort of east and
west
at the end of the day you've got to
shoot in a way that you've that's
comfortable and that puts the biggest
smile on your face
because it does require a certain amount
of fitness certain amount of stamina to
shoot because it's that you know they're
they're not easy to pull back and you've
got to hold sometimes tremendous weights
for
you know a good few seconds before you
make the shot you know various lifting
weights
isn't necessarily going to work the
archery muscles
that is actually a good archery muscle
he's working there that's going to do
more for him than bench press in wheels
you can use stretchy bands things like
that that sort of builds up muscles and
and whatnot see i want to give a really
low score but i like the working out
with the with the ropes so i'm going to
push it up i'm going to give it a 4.
she's using sound
to make a deer move into a
more
accessible shot which is fine but i
would imagine a deer would have just
bolted at that stage the you know from
my experience they're pretty skittish
things what are you gonna do with that
when you kill it
i like it personally when you're at full
draw you come you come to anchor and
you're there you know if you're doing
all this the shot's gone you need to
have focus
she actually has beautiful form in this
film and she was coached by an olympic
archer called the katuna lorick yeah
an american olympic archer again a
fantastic archer so her form
is is an olympic form which is which is
fantastic for target archery
now she's in a hunting scenario that
type of archery isn't necessarily going
to work fantastically well in this sort
of scenario
there's so many variables you're uphill
you're downhill there's you're waiting
at full draw for something to come into
to shot
she's doing a bit of wing shooting there
she's shooting a bird shooting a moving
target is also difficult
um and you wouldn't be able to to use an
olympic style of shooting to shoot a
moving target
now they look like huge plastic
feathers
um and she's shooting off the shelf
that's
not necessarily going to work out too
well the sort of boat she's got there is
he's not million miles away from from
this type of boat that's called a shelf
so the arrow sits sits on there and
as the arrow passes over the reason why
uh traditional archers use feathers is
because they they compress and they
don't really cause too much of an issue
where if you're shooting plastic
feathers like those
that they're not going to compress like
a featherwood and that's going to
that's going to cause some fouling on
there on the shelf
shooting a broad head which is a hunting
arrow it's a two-bladed
uh broadhead and it's stuck into the
target quite realistically that's kind
of how a broadhead would stick into a
hard target
even a light poundage bow would probably
do that it's not hardwired into the
pig's mouth or anything it would just
rest in there so i don't think it would
take it take a huge amount i mean i've
tried to shoot apples before
and what tends to happen
is the arrow just goes straight through
the the apple so you knock it off
whatever you're shooting but i i i've
yet to pin one to a wall the type of
archery i do it's called instinctive
archery cause i don't use a sight and i
let my my mind and my brain and my
muscle memory work subconsciously
to
let me know where to shoot that's what
she's doing there i would imagine she's
she's although she's got a very olympic
style where she's looking at something
and she's just
bang and and she nailed it i've always
got a soft spot for the hunger games you
know i'm gonna give it seven
the whole battery of archers is gonna is
gonna really mess some orcs up which is
which is what's happening there i can't
see the types of arrow points they're
using but i've seen a lot of films
people using broadheads and tuna armor
and that wouldn't work there were
certain arrow points that were designed
to go straight through armor like a
bodkin it's pointy but it's bulbous and
it's stiffer and it was designed to kind
of punch through
armor
his elbow's a bit high
but you know i'll give him that when you
got some big orc dude with a stick
coming at you you're not always going to
get chance to set and make the perfect
shot but in order to speed shoot to that
kind of level
you'd need a pretty light poundage bow
i'm gonna go four but it's cool
this is more of an eastern style his
arrow is really short
and it's actually he's got like a piece
of bamboo on the arrow attached to the
bow where the short arrow will
because obviously the longer the arrow
the heavier the shorter the arrow the
lighter the lighter something is the
further it's going to go the faster it's
going to go so it means you can pull the
bow back all the way and put maximum
maximum juice into that little arrow
he's using his thumb
uh typically the you over you over draw
with that style of archery you relax
that hand and come away from the thumb
and let the string
you can see the focus in his face
breathing is is a weird one some people
hold their breath some people breathe
through the shot if you're hunting uh
and and you're waiting for a deer to
sort of come
into view you could be holding for
a good
10 15 20 seconds olympic archers
tend to hold for a lot longer some
people are even even quicker some people
come to full draw and then make the shot
i guess if you can't drop him straight
away you can
you can wound him and then
chase him down and
poke him with something else obviously
if there was a barb on it you couldn't
pull it out you'd kind of have to pull
it through which i meant would be agony
that to me looked like a sharpened stick
so
yeah you could probably pull that out
medieval archers used to do um when they
put their arrow points on
they would put them on with um
wax if they hit you
oh you pull it out the the the point
still in you or if you missed it landed
on the floor the point would come off so
it couldn't be shot back at you but
weirdly archers nowadays are more likely
to be injured by the knock end than the
the pointy end because when that's in
the target people walk up and stumble
and things and that can be quite sharp
i'm gonna give that one nine thank you
for watching if you enjoyed that video
then click up there and watch the one
above